cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com all right let's jump into
this first story this is this is
absolutely insane this is from messenger
politics Donald Trump's New York
business Empire must be dissolved judge
rules legal experts have described the
extraordinarily rare order issued by a
New York judge aimed at Trump's major
businesses as the corporate death
penalty crazy look at this a New York
judge on Tuesday canceled the
certificates of the key businesses
behind Donald Trump's Empire ordering a
quick timeline to dissolve the Trump
organization and other corporate
entities okay there's so much here first
I don't know exactly how Trump runs his
businesses but I have to imagine Trump
is a New York guy famously coming in and
saving the city and the state which
means I'm assuming his businesses are
registered many of them in New York and
I would imagine are operating as a
foreign corporation in other states
that's what it's called so you thought
you file that now considering how long
he's been around I would not be
surprised if the bulk of his business
may actually be out of Delaware or
Nevada We we'll see but this is
this is New York
Trump has there's there's documentaries
about how New York was failing and Trump
came in and said I'm going to turn this
city around and he did and he's got how
many buildings does he have in New York
I mean official Trump buildings are two
of them well he has like a whole thing
on the West Side there's a bunch of
Trump Towers on the west side yeah well
he's got like a whole Enterprise over
there
um and then he's also got the Trump
Tower which is right I want to say it's
right near Columbus Circle I know that
I've been there before oh I've got my
Maga hat there in 2017. right yeah
that's that's the that's the
International Hotel the Trump
International yeah and then he also has
a Trump Tower
on Fifth Avenue I went to a party in the
penthouse there once it was amazing
there's this giant golden Trump building
there I was like you know what I think
I'm getting the Maga hat and so I just
walked in it was awesome yeah I mean
Trump did an awful lot for the city he
was born there he was raised there and
these are people who have been
determined to take him down Leticia
James the Attorney General of New York
state ran her campaign on Destroy Donald
Trump so did stupid Alf and brag in
Manhattan who's of course working to
destroy Donald Trump all of these people
they just hate him so much this is this
is it's it's not it doesn't seem to have
any real legal basis even this judge
hates Trump and has said so before
so they're saying that uh basically we
have this from CNBC Trump and Company
liable for fraud in New York lawsuit
judge rules this is not even a criminal
proceeding that's right this is a civil
case and they are so so look at this the
messenger says 10 corporate entities djt
revocable trust revocable trust right
I'm assuming that has something to do
with his personal life which is likely
where he holds certain properties in his
personal portfolio or family not related
to uh so it depends I mean you never
really no I mean you could do a lot of
stuff with trust but I'm assuming the
trust is probably for holding his
property a personal stuff the Trump
organization the Trump organization LLC
those right there I mean that's that's
it that's that's Trump the Trump
organization this is this is nuts and
then they mentioned a bunch of others
like djt Holdings managing member LLC
some of these are you know whatever 401
North Wabash Venture LLC this is
basically a a just a building Trump Old
Post Office LL LC 40 Wall Street LLC
basically when you buy big property you
create it yeah you create a private
entity that owns that property why okay
if uh if you regular citizens sir many
of you own homes if you own two houses
and someone slips and falls in one they
can sue and take your take both your
houses you create a corporate entity it
Shields you to a certain degree so it
always makes more sense to start a
Company the company owns the property
you own the company and that limits
liability hey how about that so this
means they're canceling the business
that owns a building yeah so Trump has a
lot of these corporations that own
buildings and they're canceling them on
him
um I wonder what's gonna happen to
Mar-A-Lago well uh Mar-A-Lago is Florida
and Don Jr owns it I believe really I
believe he turned it over to Don Jr a
good few years ago so they say
outstanding I wouldn't be surprised if
he doesn't own as much after his uh term
as president right maybe Bedminster I
don't see Bedminster on there so they
say Trump's attorney Alina Haba vowed to
appeal the decision which she called
fundamentally flawed at every level the
fact that this court summarily found
that there is no question of fact
finding in part that Mar-A-Lago is worth
approximately 20 million dollars and
issue a decision of this magnitude as an
affront to our legal system we intend to
immediately appeal this decision because
president Trump and his family like
every American business owner is
entitled to their day in court so it was
a summary judgment
that doesn't seem at all reasonable well
I mean okay I gotta be I didn't even
know that that doesn't this story is is
breaking but hold on hold on they say
judge Arthur engarin canceled New York
business advocates for Trump trump
organization other defendants including
two of his sons wow and they dismissed
the lawsuit against Ivanka I think in
June but is this was this a summary
judgment the spokes were so this is
attorney general Leticia James she filed
this and then the judge just banged the
devil yeah uh and Gordon granting
partial summary judgment to James the
case found that Trump made false
misleading valuations this means Trump
didn't even come and argue the judge
just so they filed their paperwork they
file their arguments and the judge goes
nah done yo wow yeah that's really
messed up if they are if they're you
know if they can actually essentially
take the property by a summary judgment
uh I mean then obviously that that means
that no one's property is safe anymore
well which is of course what Trump's
been saying this whole time is that
they're you know he's between
the the essential police and law fair
State and the rest of us I I I I gotta
stop this is this is crazy look at this
and Grand also ordered sanctions of 7
500 for five attorneys who represented
the Trump defendants for making
frivolous and previously rejected
arguments in court filings this is crazy
you're not allowed to you're not allowed
to represent Trump they're doing that in
Georgia too I mean they went for his
attorney to call any to call this
unprecedented is an understatement of
the highest order unprecedented
understatement I mean it it really is
and again this and not not that I'm
trying to let you get Tim fired up again
but you know if the government is
taking people's property and stuff then
the government is acting lawlessly what
recourse do the people have if you can't
rely on the law and where does this head
I'm not going to say it but I don't see
the off ramp well
sure I think um
the the framing is wrong right because
this isn't the government because the
government implies kind of a neutral
entity that
um that takes bipartisan consideration
of all parties in the country and the
people being themselves are kind of
non-partisan entity that just exist
separate from the state it's it's like
an old it's kind of an archaic way look
at what what you have is a left-wing
Insurgent movement 100 that has taken
over your country and it's now
persecuting the former president yeah
this no I I like
I it you can't overstate just how over
your country is
it's not just bad right a country is
predicated on Goodwill between both
parties you you don't have Goodwill what
you have is an active persecution of the
former president man your country is
over and now what's being settled is who
gets to rule over the ruins all right
look look you know I certainly think we
have our issues here in the United
States but I think you know hey Phil
someone's a little salty about 70 76
over here oh man I was gonna say I mean
the man who comes from Empire but I'm
I'm very much in the dock that hey 7076
was a good thing and Trump should never
have had a mug shot no I agree you're
living in a Banana Republic and you're
I've heard it's being persecuted I've
heard Carl say that the United States is
actually the the total fulfillment of
the English common law of what England
was supposed to be before so I I know
that he doesn't have the uh so it's so
it's it's constitutional republic Envy
I've become a bit more conservative
since then I don't know I well because I
mean this isn't happening in my country
no you you're your government's just
going after businesses like Rumble sure
that's correct that's not my property
because uh turned down a little
campaigned on being an
she didn't say I'm going to uphold the
law and be representation of fairness
she said we are going to disrupt the
system we're going to go after Trump and
she is open about her her preferences
for left-wing causes I mean there are a
lot of uh organizations that she is
specifically persecuting these people
are fighting a war against you right you
do understand that they're actively in
arms against you with all of the legal
mechanisms they can find this is a
cultural revolution it yeah it is and
they're going to extirpate Trump from
public life as much as they can they're
going to take everything from him as
much as they can and anyone who stands
in Alliance with him I mean Rudy
Giuliani for me is crazy the fact that
you know he's got a mugshot too that
that was that was America's mail wasn't
it he's the greatest yeah he was he was
the guy at 9 11. right yeah
he's he's the guy who ridden New York of
crime right like it's before 9 11 he
cleaned up the city amazingly well right
he got rid of the mobs and stuff right
and it's really Junior can essentially
be paraded around in Chains like the
failed opposition in a Roman civil war
with Donald Trump and everyone else
around him I mean what kind of country
failed Roman civil or tell me more well
I mean well okay
Civil War basically the uh the losing
party get killed right and but that's
well that's the the they're on the path
to doing that they're not going to kill
Donald Trump they're just going to ruin
him so he's like oh oh blind belisarius
begging for pennies outside of the road
I don't know that they wouldn't kill him
should it look like he's going to win
if they could they would but they won't
they might try and kill him before I
mean did you see him what's her name um
Megan Kelly was talking about that yeah
no no they're going to do this she was
saying that she's concerned that people
that people are going to try and
assassinate Trump yeah I think I think
the time for that has passed I think
they've got the machine in motion and
what they're going to do is just
systematically grind down Trump and
everyone associated with him everything
Maga everything protesters they're going
to stigmatize it's Terrors but this is
why they've been doing already yeah yeah
and so I I do think it's not just Trump
I think this is what we see with Russell
Brand as well there's it makes no sense
to me that they all of a sudden decided
to start investigating and caring about
what Russell Brand did decades ago when
at the time they certainly didn't care
and they've protected much worse the
thing about Russell Brand though is this
was an intentional media takedown you
had the times in London they started
doing this investigation into Russell
Brand they're the ones who contacted
these women the women said they were
only prepared to come forward after
they'd been contacted by press they also
said that they were only coming forward
because they were encouraged to come
forward now in as a reaction to Bran's
Newfound success they didn't like that
that's what was published in the times
and then you had right after that you
had NBC start contacting
all of the advertisers who sponsored
brand on YouTube you know and like on
all of his channels it was NBC reaching
out that got you know what Vivo Barefoot
or whatever else and The Sticker Mule
company to say that they were going to
disavow Brandon pull it and then after
that the news movement which is this
company that was founded in 2020
launched last year is owned by some
people who used to work for the Dow
Jones and BBC they then started going
after rumbles advertisers after Rumble
said that they backed free speech and
backed Russell Brand this other
organization went after their
advertisers this was a concerted effort
and of course you had the British
government I do we do have a story I
want to I want to talk about in a bit
about Russell Brand but the reason I
bring this up and I think it no I think
it it it's it's warranted is because the
conversation doesn't stop with Trump
they are as you said call trying to ruin
him but this does not stop with Trump
it's it's it's especially right now as
we're entering 2024 we know that you
know what was it 2018 I said this last
night with Alex Jones and they went
after Paul Joseph Watson Alex Jones uh
uh Laura Loomer that's right Donald
Trump eventually they will get to Joe
Rogan absolutely yeah because Joe Rogan
is has now repeated himself with Patrick
uh David saying that he would vote for
Trump over Biden I mean you cannot have
this no so they they there is an effort
here and I think if you look at at
Julian Assange as an example of how they
deal with this surprise surprise oh
Russell Brand me too all the stuff it is
is a similar theme Donald Trump same
thing in uh was it Bergdorf was it the
yeah Goodmans yep they said that he
showed up no one noticed and they found
him liable notice they're not doing
criminal charges in New York they're
finding him liable why because a judge
can bang the gavel you don't have the
same kind of Rights
it is genuinely terrifying however I
want to say this to you Carl
I think we're winning
I don't see it so when you look at the
culture see the evidence for it well so
so first how many of their guys are in
jail why why why is that the standard by
which we determine if we're winning or
losing what is the standard so the
standard is economic factors and
cultural factors and I think if you look
at the cultural victories particularly
pronounced ones you can see the shift in
the minds of the people and what
confidence of the people will allow
right now Joe Biden is tanking he's
sinking in the polls we're seeing woke
corporations get decimated we're seeing
indie films Skyrocket Indie artist
Skyrocket we're seeing a collective of
of uh anti-establishment individuals and
more people I'm seeing on Twitter for
instance this doctor I've retweeted who
says I was wrong in 2020 I shouldn't
have supported Biden what what many of
us experienced for me and for me in
particular I think in like 2020 when my
attitude towards Trump in 2016 was nah
yeah get out of here with this magnitude
later on was like well I'm not going to
vote for the guy but I can understand
what people are saying about him and
then in 22
but then in 2020 I was like the agenda
he released lays out too many points
that I've agreed with and it would be
hypocritical for me to say I would not
support that
so that's that's pre-2020. now we're
seeing more people who voted for Biden
in 2020 who did not have that Revelation
now saying I totally get it I'm voting
for Trump yeah I I see these things Bud
Light Target Disney Netflix
to that as well Marriott Marriott we
need to add marriage what happened with
Marriott uh Marriott was the hotel that
canceled Andy knows talk after antifa
called and harassed them and so that
Hotel chain needs the Bud Light
treatment but look at the the rise of
the parallel economy so at first you
could argue yes we're losing because
they're debanking people they're
censoring people and there were attempts
to to counter this right parlor and then
they destroy parlor but then a couple
things happen
Carl you're back on on X your Twitter
yeah but that wasn't because
um of any Goodwill in the establishment
no of course not it's because a powerful
individual who views the world more
closely to how we view it in terms of
what should or should not be
took great risk to buy the platform to
in my opinion pursue his personal goals
but it also had a tremendous effect of
bringing back a lot of the people who
are Thanos snapped out of the
conversation so now you're back on
Twitter
right so you see a move like that Rumble
their spec deal according to the Motley
Fool Chris Chris pavlovski the CEO is a
billionaire okay I don't know how Chris
feels about me saying that but like the
Motley Fool says here's how many shares
he owns at this price
if that's true he's a tech billionaire
okay and this means when you see the
tremendous support that new platforms
are getting and the success of platforms
like the daily wire with the failures
this is why I think you see what they're
doing in New York does it is any is is
this going to help them I don't think it
helps them in the long run I think there
are a lot of communist banality of evil
types who will cheer for it no matter
what but I do think there's going to be
a lot of regular people who are going to
start going like dude this is freaking
out you're scaring me I talk to people
touch grass as it were and I'll say
something like what do you think about I
hate Trump screw that don't care and
then their real attitude the reason why
they hate Trump and when I'm gone is
they're like I'm tired of conflict I'm
tired of the noise I'm tired of the
fighting I want stability and guess what
this doesn't stop with Trump but but the
point here is these people don't realize
they don't realize they think make Trump
go away and they leave us alone wrong no
that is wrong yeah now what I'm hearing
I'm hanging out the poker tables and
there is this lib guy and and I'm
talking to a guy in front of me who's
like a fan this guy chimes in when we're
talking about Trump and he goes look hey
I I hate Trump but you know they they
shouldn't be doing these these suits to
get him off the ballot that's that's
crazy and I'm like right what's gonna
happen is these regular people who are
begging for normalcy are now realizing
the things they're doing with shutting
down the Trump organization Prosecuting
him is the conflict and Trump is the
solution we have the situation where you
have the people who are in power
distinctly not listening to the
constituents at all on any topic on any
area of of governance whatsoever so I
think that's what we're seeing too is
we're seeing normal people be like these
lawsuits are bogus you know mutilating
kids is bogus we don't want any of that
opening the borders and destroying our
national sovereignty that's a terrible
idea you know you're seeing all of this
stuff and the more constituents speak
out which they are doing you know we see
the polling we see all this stuff we see
people speaking out against it and the
ruling class doesn't care at all you
know they're so used to just shoving
their elitist opinions down our throats
and I say this as a you know recovering
elitist they like they're shoving this
all down our throats and we're just
supposed to take it and people don't
want to take it anymore but I do
I do wonder if we're actually winning
like it it feels a lot feels a lot like
being destroyed I I think you have to be
careful of of listen Trump is ahead in
the polls yeah Trump is ahead in the
prediction markets but don't you think
they're gonna take him out don't you
think they're gonna find a way to like
I'm not that's why they're doing all of
this it's desperation thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time